The joe rogan experience.
We got, you know this,
if you ever do those, use those yonder
bags. You know those bags are in the mix.
You put their cell phone in
the back end for has them.
Denver uses them for all the shows now.
I started using them for all my shows.
So you just accompany, comes in and just
does it for you. Yeah, you hire them,
they come in and then when they
put the bag, the phone in the bag,
they still hold onto their phone.
They can leave the room
if they get a phone call,
like you have a kid or something like
that and someone's watching the kid,
you can always get out of
the room and make call,
but you can't call people
when you're in the room.
And I was having people calling
people and talking on the phone.
You could see them talking on the phone
while the show's going on and people
around them would be getting pissed off.
And uh,
someone at Twitter
comment on it and he just,
everyone's got their phones up and
look, I know I've done it too. I'm,
I'm totally a hypocrite. When I saw
honey honey with Gary Karch perform it,
this little tiny room in downtown La was
a midnight show on like a Tuesday and I
filmed it and I put it on my Instagram.
So I know I'm a hypocrite.
But that was a rare occasion
and it wasn't a comedy show.
It's like a comedy show. You have to pay
attention to what the fuck's going on.
If you, if you're filming it, you're
definitely not paying full attention.
It's just not,
you're going to miss some stuff.
It's just not the same thing when you're
filming shit. Like everybody is just,
and even if you're not,
you're checking this and checking texts
and boy we got a real addiction problem
in this country. The, these, these
are new things is new object.
I realized, cause I'm not
delusional that the amount of it,
I can put most of it to breasts with
a pre announcement where I'm at in my
career. But again, as you get to different
levels, there's different intensity.
So I don't, I get it. But, um, the, uh, I,
I changed my pre show announcement
when I went to see Brian Regan,
the person next to me, I,
they were texting, I couldn't
hear them. Matter of fact,
they even had their sh the light down.
So you think, well, what could bother me?
And it did. And it didn't matter if it
was right or wrong. I know what it was.
I wanted the person next to him and it'd
be loving him as much as I was loving
him. And the fact that I saw them
on their phone on night even,
they weren't making a peep.
It started to bother the fuck out of me.
I was getting angry and
then I went, oh, that's,
I'm going to do the same thing at my show.
I go,
don't turn your thing all the way
down. I go, I know what you think.
And you pull it out into
your knee. I go, seriously,
if you pull your phone out after this
announcement, do you look like a Dick?
I go and other than that, we're glad
you're here and you know what it,
you just, you have to pick
it. That announcement a
little longer, but it works.
I'm worried about people. I really
are. This is a really new thing.
The more I'm thinking about it,
the more like looking at your phone
constantly is really only 10 years old,
right?
Like 2008 ish.
The not the iPhone came
around 2009 right before that.
People were a little texty people,
some people more texty than others.
They really got into text messages.
But once that iPhone came out and once
people started doing bunch of stuff and
apps and stuff on your phone, it
changed the whole game. You know?
I don't know with this topic,
if I'm like I could be way
off or I could be off kilter,
but the way I come to my conclusion
about like, you know, you know it is,
it is a weird thing and even me,
I kill acknowledge it. Otherwise,
if I don't acknowledge it,
then you're never going to tell some of
the opposing side if they don't think
you get what you see it,
but it just seems like in the past
now this could be different with no,
no snarkiness it.
Oh,
this could be a different thing every
time they think there's one of these
things like TV radio to
seems like when we get past,
oh I think we'll get past it.
You know what I mean?
I didn't know think the world was going
to explode. I'm worried about certain,
I'm not worried about the human race,
but I'm worried about the lives of
certain people, if that makes sense.
Because it's like saying like,
are you worried that cracks
can destroy the human race? No,
I'm not worried that crack
is going to destroy it,
but I do think it can destroy the lives
of some people and I feel the same way
about this. Right? Like the texting,
like it's not just that it's,
it's like being plugged into electronic
to the point where that's where you're
getting most of your stimuli from.
You're getting artificial stimuli.
My concerns is a real
concern is that we're,
we're getting really into that and then
we're going to let it take the next step,
which is some sort of an implant.
I feel like this is why we're in a movie
and we're going to move you about a
person that becomes a machine and we're
watching this rationalization process.
As we slowly get more and more ingrained
and inner connected with technology,
we'll definitely in our
lifetime have somebody 100%.
I try like what you were just
addressing. Like we said before, like I,
I catch myself and I really try.
Like if I had to give myself a grade on
how much I've improved and like turning
the phone off,
like loving it for what's great about it,
I give myself maybe a c minus,
but it means I've made some strides and
like turning it off. You're not enough.
Not enough for a matter of fact.
Uh,
I remember a week ago I was
going to the grove and I went,
I'm not meeting anybody. Um, and I left
my phone in the car. It was strong. Move
strong. No, it sucked
because I had two ideas.
I had two ideas and I was
high and I didn't want to
write them down. I went ass.
Shit. That's the thing about
leaving your phone in the car.
I take a picture or show someone a
picture or it doesn't have to always be,
but anyway, I try to go and, you
know, never, never walking through,
never walking through a line that
actually could encourage you to write. Um,
you know,
you could just use hate writing.
Okay.